many of the participants in the siege of
the capitol earlier this month
have been identified you know how the
fbi
identified the people who took over the
capital
thanks to their own posts on social
media isn't that crazy yeah
it's crazy i mean there's another word
for it stupid yeah
uh check this out one man was arrested
after the fbi looked up his google
search history
yeah well of course this uh entire
event at the capitol was a terrible
stain on our country's democracy
but one company has
found the upside has this ever happened
to you
a tennessee man was arrested today after
the fbi looked through his google search
history and found the phrase
all going to dc the cavalry is coming
did you know that the third most common
form of evidence in a treason case
is the suspect's google search history
that's where bing comes in
yup that big from microsoft if you're
searching for ways to commit treason
don't google it i've been an fbi agent
for
25 years now and i've never ever heard
of bing it would just not occur to me to
check a suspect's
bing history what is bing is it
like a weed term bing from microsoft
no one's heard of us
you